[Música]
de verdad
ocho de cada diez se equivocan
y una de ellas
[Música]
esto
bueno
tengo una razón por la que él
así que puedo poner en duda mi
inteligencia si quiero dos veces y
obviamente las dos veces
así que poner en duda mi inteligencia y
decidir una carrera por eso no soy una
humanidad
la razón querer complacer a mis papás
estudiando algo de estudiar
y cuánta razón por dinero
para la razón
escribir estable medicina también dicen
el normal del estado para restar
porque bien
y medicinas
hoy estoy segura que no voy a lo que
quería
entonces
no me gusta la medida
si yo hubiera estudiado medicina
sí no
conmigo misma
pero ahora
me equivoqué
información
de que iba a aprender a cuidar niños
o
sobre el ser humano desde su gestación
hasta los zetas los primeros seis años
de vida después lo que era la
complejidad de la mente los procesos de
aprendizaje las inteligencias
desde ese momento la educación es de mi
pasión
después de eso comencé a decir
y yo
[Aplausos]
con él
la normal yo quería transformar el mundo
con la educación
y qué
bueno
cuando mis sueños
favoritos y el último puente
y
ahora como me di cuenta y justo en este
momento
cuatro meses tuvieron esta actitud de
apatía de movimiento dentro
a diario
y estaba escribiendo emociones
[Música]
acción
qué
así que comencé a reflexionar
por qué
después de mi conversación con dios
entrevisté a varias personas
personas eran felices con lo que hacían
y otras personas no lo eran
y yo en ese momento
un determinado de los felices de la piel
debía tener a sus propósitos
y van tras sus sueños y algunos de ellos
querían
de personas felices
luís a
es esperar
recordé a qué es
o la educación
es un trabajo convertí en la ola en un
centro de investigación y a mis alumnos
sabía que todo lo aprendido
y nuevos cursos aprender de todo pero
sobre todo quisiera crecer y desarrollar
mi área emocional
y la desconexión que tuve de niños de 5
años a cerca
en familia
necesita comprar estos productos
necesitamos
cuánto dinero necesita
y para conseguir este dinero
y me
maestra el dinero viene de las personas
y cómo va a hacer que las personas
y yo he visto a personas que va a
repicar en las plazas y pasan un
sombrerito y les dan dinero
y si nosotros les decimos para qué
queremos ese dinero más fácil
hoy
los padres
estábamos en la plaza
cantando bailando
a los niños
a la mesa y se la llevaron
muy nos divertimos
interesante
y ahora
primera elección
y se hace con los sueños se comparten
porque las personas
puede ayudar a lograr la segunda
te diviertes generando dinero y el
dinero no es un límite para ellos para
y tercero
cuando sea
cuando hoy miramos
y en los sueños se pueden hacer realidad
cuando cambiamos
él es un sueño por elegir una carrera
profesional
tiempo estaría si en lugar de pujar y
motivaría para que desde niños de lista
en una carrera profesional conocían
grandes los empujamos los enseñamos
elegido un sueño
no habría más personas felices
yo soy feliz con ese manualidad sigo
creyendo que puede ser posible
transformar ambiente con la educación y
por eso tome la responsabilidad declaró
modelo educativo que potencialice
todas sus áreas
y quien les enseñe que les vamos a
enseñar el escritorios de lugar de
elegir profesiones
porque entonces había más personas
felices
entonces por qué no hacemos la felicidad
y una persona logra su sueño ya esta
realidad su sueño es más feliz y permite
a otros realizar sus sueños y ser más
felices así que los invito a que elija
sus sueños y sus sueños que termine su
carrera
[Aplausos]